the umbrellas the human species has been
protecting itself from the rain of the sun since
they have existed
I almost claim to do the
oldest job in the world
[Music]
my name is tir millet we call back
Mr Peps because I run a small
business that  is called sorrows and
therefore no longer seems old passage of paris
here we repair and by calling
packs and
canes home peps at the church for 47 years
soon 48 years so I hope to do the
50 years sorrows passes between  a pleasure
peace to the people it is unique in europe
international tic d'europe dedicated to
its repair umbrella beautiful marsh of
kaw would not have succeeded between 1.8 and
1000 umbrellas
each year one can be a good
repairer of umbrellas one must  be
patient
look it's going to retouch things it
's only mikado the effort in the
parts and knowing how to reassemble them where to
disassemble them the assembly it makes a
harmony oddly it's the
taste buds cheaper I have more  ur to
repair what the materials are of
poor quality
so that it is more difficult to repair
choices to resist but we also
do but do not repeat supported very well
done everything to subdue and llodra but
crowded
the magic fingers it is  it comes out and
parra cap and childlike simplicity
it's not beautiful that on the most magical
context and it greets today in
their umbrella operations not because
you have to get up early in the morning and
work a lot when when
customers come who  would not have called
a little who thought around selling
to restore first of all it's the most
beautiful story that tells us
very personal effort it puts me
under impossible pressure because I
have to repair and when umbrella to
restore in his words and his bags a
marvelous because the cndd in senso
timone in the emotion we are not in
the rational we are in the emotion
the players love